forget IP ownership and movie rights and
all that legal nonsense there's one
reason and one reason only the x-men
universe has to stay separate from the
rest of Marvel's properties because you
know magneto would have his way with
anyone named Iron Man quickest battle
ever
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that's calling out the film
industry for a serious lack of
imagination in their posters this year
Batman V Superman Civil War neighbors to
noticing a pattern here guys and sure
the trend nowadays is to just slap two
superheroes together and have them Duke
it out the x-men have been doing that
for well over a decade these mutants
never got along
come on Wolverine you don't have to
punch Deadpool in the face
hey a Jean Grey would be great if you
didn't disintegrate Cyclops all right
Charles Eric can the two of you act like
adults and not try to kill each other
for just one movie no no not even once
and it ain't stopping anytime soon
either since there's another mutant war
on the horizon in x-men apocalypse so
knowing that it's high time we start
looking into the powers of these extra
normal humans and prep some strategies
for how to handle some of the
franchise's heaviest hitters and who
better to start with than Magneto I mean
when I was a wee eight-year-old
educating my classmates on the proper
hand hand traction for swinging on the
monkey bars there was only one thing I
wanted to be a mutant sign me up for
Xavier school for gifted youngsters aka
American Hogwarts teach me how to throw
a car with my mind or shoot laser beams
out of my eyes or freeze a pencil in
thin air you know practical everyday
useful stuff or at least as useful as I
found calculus to be in my everyday life
but amongst all the awesome mutants and
awesome powers there is one who stood
out from the rest the most awesome one
of all magneto
and yeah yeah flame or in the comments
all you Wolverine fans please snikt away
your retractable claws and get honest
with yourselves for a moment Wolverine
is great don't get me wrong but can he
stop a bullet in midair can he lift a
car without even touching it head he fly
I don't think so you know who can
magneto and probably storm two she could
probably do those things Jean along with
a few others in the x-men universe since
those sorts of powers aren't really that
rare to come by that just makes
Wolverines inability to do them all the
more unacceptable but will be rants
aside when you really look at it the
story of the x-men movies for the last
15 years has truly been the story of
Magneto
his relationship with Professor X and
yet in writing this episode I was
disillusioned because for his grandiose
as he talks and his
powerful as he seems when you get right
down to it magneto is one of the most
vulnerable mutants in all of these films
the guy's a glass cannon powerful but
fragile and his biggest weakness one
that you could use to take him down
yourself is one that you probably
wouldn't expect now to truly appreciate
Magneto's one fatal flaw we have to
first understand just how he does what
he does what makes the guy tick the
source behind all his powers
magnets who would have ever guessed but
for as simple as that explanation is
there's actually a lot more to it than
that no I'm gonna guess that the
elementary teacher who had you play with
horseshoe magnets and paperclips in
school didn't tell you that there are
actually six different types of magnetic
force six they you'll be looking at
those refrigerator magnets in a whole
new way now the six different types are
diamagnetism paramagnetism
ferromagnetism antiferromagnetism faerie
magnetism and super para magnetism of
those the type we're almost familiar
with is Ferro magnetism this type occurs
when an object's electrons all point the
same way attracting materials to it it's
the strongest and most easy to identify
type of magnetism and yet it only works
on items consisting of iron nickel
cobalt their alloys and a few other
naturally occurring minerals it's
actually really easy to remember
ferromagnetic from the word ferrous
meaning containing iron think back to
the periodic table we were all confused
why Fe stood for iron right well Ferro
gotta love those ancient root words and
seriously think back to those classroom
experiments you did when you were in
first grade a magnet could pick up a
paperclip largely comprised of iron but
could pick up your pencil made of wood
so simple stuff I know but I gotta make
sure that you guys stick with this
episode stick with it like a magnet all
right now while I could take you through
the other five types of magnetism after
looking through all the x-men films
magneto seems not to be the master of
magnetism so much as he is the master of
Ferro magnetism
since every single thing that magneto
lifts seems like it would have traces of
iron nickel cobalt or an alloy the
Golden Gate Bridge which magneto lifts
in x-men The Last Stand the main towers
and suspended structures are made of
steel the ballistic missiles magneto
stops in x-men first class shells made
of steel the RFK baseball stadium he
lifts in Days of Future past constructed
from a base of Steel even Wolverine
throughout the x-men films we see
magneto constantly bending and
manipulating Wolverines claws
seriously it's almost like a running
joke the number of times they've used
this trick and yet we as the movie-going
audience are always like oh he's totally
schooling Wolverine as though we didn't
just see it in like the last 30 movies
we get it his skeleton is metal all
right find a new way to beat the guy
anyway per marvel
or Wolvie skeleton claws included are
made of adamantium which despite being a
fictional metal is a very dense
artificial iron based alloy according to
Canon even fake metals have iron in them
so in short you can think of magneto as
a permanent magnet attracting and
controlling specific types of materials
this would explain why an X - x-men
United when Magneto's held in the
plastic cell he's rendered completely
powerless in order to escape the cell
mystique has to inject a prison guard
with none other than iron when the
prison guard has extra iron running
through him magneto is able to lift a
man and extract the iron from his body
much the same way a permanent magnet
does in retrospect that's a silly
sentence that would imply that permanent
magnets on the regular lifts humans
often extract iron from them gives
magnets a weird evil intent that I
didn't anticipate but just how strong of
a magnet is he well the biggest feat we
see him perform across all the movies is
that aforementioned Golden Gate Bridge
scene from last Stan a structure
weighing 887 thousand tons or 804
million kilograms based on the bridges
weight and the magnetic strength
required to generate enough lift to
levitate other much smaller objects we
were able to calculate that the strength
of Magneto's magnetic field would be in
the range of 100 million Tesla a
magnetic force that can only be found in
neutron stars by comparison
you know what the strongest magnet we
have on earth is a hundred Tesla 100 oh
yeah and by the way hashtag not spawn by
Tesla the car companies just that Nikola
Tesla did all sorts of cool stuff in
short magneto is 1 million times
stronger than any magnet we've been able
to produce here on earth that's insane
how do you stop a juggernaut like that
on the geminal pitch
that's a whole lot easier than you think
bullets seriously you just shoot him
remember magneto is ferromagnetic so not
all metal is under his control and
bullets by and large are made with a
lead core in case with a copper jacket
both of which are non-magnetic materials
which means magneto should have no more
control over a bullet than he would the
plastic cell from X 2 or even a plastic
water bottle for that matter if you
watch the series with this knowledge
you'll notice that throughout the x-men
films magneto shows very little success
at stopping bullets in the famously
awesome Quicksilver time in a bottle
sequence magneto has complete control
over all the kitchen utensils but it's
up to Quicksilver to deflect the bullets
and save Erik and Charles's life and
then at the end of Days of Future Passed
mystique shoots magneto in the neck the
movie makes it seem like this is because
Magneto's distracted by the Sentinel but
in truth it's because his magnetic
powers don't extend to bullets now I can
totally see you being skeptical about
this what about that awesome scene from
the first x-men movie where magneto is
surrounded by the police officers I hear
you saying he stops a bullet right there
and yeah you're right he does stop a
bullet in that scene let's pick it apart
shall we magneto starts the scene by
turning each of the officers guns
against them and this falls well under
the purview of his powers as most guns
are made from aluminum and steel so no
big surprise and a really cool really
intense image but then magneto fires one
of the guns and stops the bullet itself
at the base of the officers forehead if
what I'm saying is true and he can't
control bullets how's this work well my
first impulse was to say that this
bullet must be what's known as a full
metal jacket bullet and no I'm not
talking about a transmuting anime bullet
or an 80s cinema classic bullet but a
lead bullet jacketed and steel to allow
for higher velocity shooting if this
were the case it would be easy for
magneto to control except that we get a
good look at that bullet spinning in
midair
and it doesn't have the long more
aerodynamic shape of a full metal
bullets further complicating the
situation is that in the late 90s
several major cities in the US including
New York setting for the scene stopped
using full metal jacketed bullets in
favor of hollow point HST mu
ition bullets designed to expand once
they hit the intent is to cause a high
level of damage immediately around the
entry point which disables the targets
these HST bullets tend to be shorter and
rounder and are jacketed not with steel
but with copper a non-ferrous almost
completely non ferromagnetic metal
meaning that in the real world the
bullets carried by the majority of major
US cities would be totally unaffected by
Magneto's powers in other words they
would definitely pose a threat to him
but they wouldn't explain this situation
at all
so what's going on here am I completely
off the mark in my analysis of Magneto's
powers oh no watch the seat again
first notice the shape of the bullet
shorter and more rounded so it's
definitely our HST bullet but notice the
color of the bullet silver and not
yellow orange like copper also it's
important to note that this standoff is
happening at night these two facts are
essential because law enforcement
agencies have reported that in low-light
low velocity shooting situations they'll
use special nickel casings for their
hollow-point ammo nickel a metal that's
completely susceptible to ferromagnetism
and that is exactly what we're seeing
need more evidence tangents of the fact
that magneto doesn't fire at every
officer surrounding him he only fires
this one particular bullet why he
carefully searches his surroundings
almost as if he's looking for the right
gun to fire the one out of the dozens
that doesn't have lead in copper bullets
for instance he doesn't fire a shotgun
shell because shotgun shells often
contain a mix of ferrous and non-ferrous
metals no he specifically selects the
bullet he can control and if you think
I'm reading too much into it don't trust
me trust him magneto himself admits to
it I don't think I can stop them all
he's not talking about the number of
bullets he would be firing remember this
is the guy who can lift the Golden Gate
Bridge and catch dozens of missiles in
midair he honestly can't stop them all
his powers won't allow it so in the end
the master of magnetism a mutant with
power levels rivaling that of a neutron
star my favorite growing up in a man who
can rip apart bridges with a flick of
the wrist can be brought down by a
simple bullet just like you or me what
he's been able to do is fool everyone
into thinking that he can control
bullets when the vast majority of them
pose
huge threat to him forget adamantium
blades and laser eyes sometimes the most
effective weapon is the simplest I guess
giving Wolverine a hard time about not
being able to stop bullets in midair was
a bit premature but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut and hey if
you enjoyed this episode and are excited
for more x-men apocalypse action click
right here to check out my buddies over
at the wisecrack channel and their
recent video all about the philosophy of
the x-men series the annotation works on
mobile desktop tablet you name it so go
ahead click it watch their video you
have no excuse now or if you're
interested in learning how to take down
Wolverine I cover that exact subject in
my Deadpool episode because the two
actually share the exact same weakness
click right here to check that one out
and now if you'll excuse me I need a
little break from superheroes I hear
there's some Pixar movies coming out in
the near future and some lies that need
to be exposed see you next time